hey how's it going bros my name is boom
today we're playing pewdiepie my
favorite game of all time hmm alright
here's what we're gonna do if I die
anymore I will put on a piece of makeup
item to make myself become fabulous
because I'm [ __ ] beautiful and
[ __ ] need to know about it I'm
already so [ __ ] pissed
mmm smells nice
oh my god mice is gonna kill me
maybe now my skills will improve going
going use [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
checkpoint checkpoint [ __ ] flip 6 it
works oh my god go up go up yes yes yes
the lipsticks it works ok what's next
what's next
bring it on Donkey Kong look at that
moves ahh
what you gonna do I know kungfu
[ __ ] oh oh [ __ ]
uh uh uh huh what you gonna do come fo
[ __ ] oh there's a checkpoint right
[ __ ] there
MIDI out I have some blush [ __ ] love
blush this is my war paint the colors
tell my story of fury and pain
I hate my life I get it okay I get it I
get a torture machine that's what I
think that's what you bros blessed me
with I have the best fans thank you so
much love you on there is a trap here I
[ __ ] know it
oh okay
how about a rule I only apply the war
paint if I die at a place and when I
progress you know I'm saying it's my
[ __ ] video I make my own [ __ ]
rules this game is the reason I have
trust issues the jump is so simple I
don't know how I [ __ ] it up ah Oh call
Kate oven okay all right all right come
on piss ah
No oh my god yes yes
what ah it's okay I have a wide
selection of whatever these are I think
you put them on and I'm gonna look good
yes
who the [ __ ] are you this is that Toby
audience what are you doing here for
your duck Toby your dress looks fabulous
all right listen all right Toby's
helping me this is it tell me what are
you doing don't go down there Toby Toby
Toby please hit Toby Toby what are you
know job a no-stress was so pretty love
suceed all right did I need Toby to open
the door or some [ __ ] god damn it I got
damnit okay why did you have to die you
know maybe when they made this game they
sat down and they were like hey maybe
maybe this game isn't it's a little too
hard just can't hit a little bit too
hard okay no yeah
all right then all right then just me
it's my I supposed to burn is that is
that a natural effect I swear to god I'm
going to kill myself
I have to go through this [ __ ] which is
completely [ __ ] random yeah yeah and
I can't even jump through those so what
am I supposed to do I will [ __ ] cut
off my balls and feed them to the cows
oh my god
come on come on I don't have time I
don't have [ __ ] time for you Oh Toby
[ __ ] me Tommy oh where do you go where
do you go Wendy till we go Toby Toby
this is not funny
Toby that [ __ ] disappeared are you
telling me I can't do it now because
Toby disappeared get this game released
out I can't do it that's fair that's
very fair I agree 100% with this
decision of the game developer I can't
go in there now pushed Obito in Toby's
Joey did Toby just tojust Joey
dick
I have a pretty girl don't disappear
follow Toby don't have a pretty girl
Oh